se me ha pedido hacer un vídeo sobre el
producto cruz tú sabes circunstancias
especiales porque estaba en la etapa de
mi vida donde estaba enseñando en las
listas de física magnetismo así que es
una buena hora para enseñar al menos la
noción de lo que es producto cruz aunque
bueno vamos a ir más allá de hecho vamos
a hacer ejemplos y todo que es el
producto cruz sabemos sobre suma de
vectores resta de vectores pero qué
sucede cuando nos multiplicamos a estos
vectores hay dos maneras de multiplicar
vectores uno sería el producto punto y
el otro el producto cruz bueno cada
operación que hemos aprendido está
definida por humanos para algún fin y
bueno nada hay diferente en el producto
cruz y bueno que es el producto cruz al
menos cuando yo lo aprendí parecía un
poco sobrenatural pero bueno no te voy a
enseñar lo que es digamos que yo tengo
aquí el vector a cruz el vector b y la
anotación es como el signo de
multiplicar que usabas en la primaria
ahora ya crisis t y bueno utilizas el
punto o los paréntesis y bueno que ya
entonces
el producto cruz de los vectores ahí ve
es igual es igual aunque va a parecer
algo algo medio bizarro al inicio pero
ya lo visualizaremos es igual a la
magnitud del vector a x la magnitud del
vector b que multiplica también al seno
del ángulo entre ellos y yo aquí hablo
de él del ángulo más pequeño entre ellos
ahora aquí viene lo interesante esta
cantidad la que nos va a dar no será una
cantidad de escala no solamente tendrá
magnitud también tendrá dirección y esa
dirección la especificamos con la letra
n es el vector en el vector unitario n y
hay varias cosas especiales de esta
dirección en primera es que el vector n
es perpendicular a ambos sectores a y b
guau y sus meses magia
la magia y las matemáticas es ortogonal
a ambos vectores entonces bueno
pensaremos que que implica visualmente
eso
y en otra en segundo lugar es que éste
define está definida por la regla de la
mano derecha también lo veremos en un
segundo
intentaremos pensar en esto visualmente
también otra cosa es que solamente
puedes tomar el producto cruz cuando
estamos en tres dimensiones quizás
puedas definirlo en otras dimensiones
pero en realidad solamente sólo tiene
tiene uso en tres dimensiones y eso es
perfecto porque vivimos en un mundo un
mundo tridimensional entonces tomamos
algunos productos crudos y bueno cuando
lo visualice estará totalmente más
sentido en especial cuando cuando te
acostumbres a la regla de la mano
derecha digamos que este es el vector ve
y dibujo otro vector en color rosa bueno
quedó chico entonces es que no estoy
usando la herramienta de línea pero ya
está así que aquí está el vector
este es el vector a y lo que queremos
hacer es tomar el producto cruce entre
ellos entonces este es el vector
este es el vector b y el ángulo entre
ellos digamos que es teta así que aquí
está teta ahora digamos que la longitud
de a es no lo sé supongamos que que 5 y
que la longitud la magnitud de b es
supongamos que 1010 solamente estoy bien
aventando aquí números no son exactos
entonces cuál es el producto cruz bueno
pues la parte de la magnitud es sencilla
y digamos que supongamos que el ángulo
es igual a 30 grados así lo queremos ver
en radiales aunque me parece más
sencillo en en grados porque así crecí
pero en radiales 30 grados en términos
de radiales es y sextos entonces aquí
escribo esto es igual en radiales es
igual a pi sobre 6
y aquí tenemos un ángulo de 30 grados
entonces que será a cruz ven
cruz ve será igual va a ser igual a la
magnitud de a será igual a 5 por la
longitud del vector bm entonces por 10
pero el seno del ángulo entre ellos y
claro podrías tú tomar también el ángulo
obtuso el de este lado pero al inicio
del vídeo yo dije que el más pequeño
dije que tomaríamos el ángulo agudo
entre estos vectores entonces será por
el seno de 30 grados multiplicado por
este vector n el cual es un vector
unitario entonces en un momento
mencionaré en qué dirección apunta a
dicho vector esto es igual a 50 entonces
pongo aquí 50 y cuál es el seno de 30
grados el seno de 30 grados es un medio
por el vector n
el vector unitario esto es igual a 25
por el vector unitario y aquí es donde
se pone desde tu punto de vista ya sea
bueno interesante o confuso en qué
dirección apunta este vector como lo
dije antes es perpendicular a ambos de
estos vectores entonces como puede ser
algo perpendicular a ambos vectores
parece como si fuera imposible dibujar
uno y se debe a que aquí donde yo dibujé
el vector aire estoy operando en dos
direcciones es un plano pero si tengo
una tercera dirección si de alguna
manera puedo hacer salir o entrar de mi
blog en el que escribo bueno en tu caso
sería tu pantalla entonces tengo un
vector que es perpendicular a ambos
entonces imagina que un vector que está
justo frente de ti aquí en este punto
como que está saliendo y bueno te voy a
mostrar una amd una notación para esto
si yo dibujo un vector así si dibujo un
círculo con un una equis adentro es un
vector que entra a la página o que entra
a la pantalla y si yo dibujo esto esto
es un vector que está sobresaliendo de
la pantalla y bueno de dónde viene esta
convención viene de una flecha baja como
como se ve una flecha una
hecha la cual es nuestra convención para
dibujar vectores una fecha se mira algo
así la punta de la flecha está así
circular digamos y bueno llega a una
punta bueno usa la imaginación más o
menos sale del vídeo y el extremo
opuesto de la flecha tiene como atletas
algo así bueno de hecho porque se llaman
plumas entonces si tomamos esta pluma si
entraras a la pantalla y mirar a esta
parte de la flecha se miraría algo así
este es un vector que entra a la
pantalla este es un vector que sale de
la pantalla entonces sabemos que en es
perpendicular a ambos a y b y la única
manera que puede tener un vector que sea
perpendicular a ambos a ive debe ser
perpendicular o normal ortogonal a este
plano ajá el plano que es tu pantalla de
la computadora en la que me escuchas
pero como sabemos si sale de la pantalla
o entra y aquí vamos a dar la bienvenida
a lo que se llama la regla de la mano
derecha
yo sé que es algo confuso pero haremos
varios ejemplos la regla de la mano
derecha am lo que hace es bueno tú tomas
tu mano derecha así que toma tu mano
derecha y bueno esto se llama así por
eso porque es la mano derecha tomas tu
dedo índice y lo apuntasen dirección del
primer vector en el producto cruz y
bueno cabe mencionar que el orden si
importa entonces hagámoslo de mes debes
tomar tu dedo índice y ponerlo en
dirección de la de la primera flecha que
es el vector a luego tomas tu dedo medio
y lo apuntasen dirección de la segunda
fecha que es el vector b así que en este
caso tu mano se verá algo así a intento
dibujarla y bueno estoy viendo mi mano a
ver bueno veamos si puedo hacer esto mis
habilidades artísticas no son muy buenas
es algo así mano derecha mi pulgar está
hacia abajo así más o menos
bueno esta es mi mano derecha este es mi
dedo índice y bueno como que apunta en
dirección del vector y luego mi dedo
medio lo hago como la figura de la letra
l entonces apunta en dirección del
vector de mi dedo medio y cualquier
dirección a la que apunta el pulgar en
este caso tu pulgar entra en la página
cierto tu pulgar iría hacia abajo en
esta consideración entonces esto nos
dice que el vector n apunta hacia dentro
de la página el vector n tiene magnitud
25 entonces apunta hacia dentro de la
página podríamos dibujarlo algo así con
una equis si intentar hacerlo en tres
dimensiones se miraría am algo así el
vector a bueno vamos a ver si le puedo
dar una perspectiva a esto si esto fuera
así si va hacia abajo si ese es el
vector n entonces podría verse algo así
bueno mejor lo hago con el mismo color
de a este es el vector an
y ve se va a ver en verde así intentó
dibujar una figura de tres dimensiones
en dos dimensiones entonces se verá algo
raro pero supongo te da la noción acá
están los vectores en el plano
aquí hay perspectiva donde puede donde
puedo dibujar a n entonces yendo hacia
abajo pero esta es la definición de
producto cruz entonces bueno le voy a
dejar aquí en este vídeo hablaré en
otros vídeos y pondré varios ejemplos
donde tomaremos el producto cruz y
hablaremos sobre magnetismo entonces
bueno nos vemos